hello thank you very much I'm proud and
excited to be here today to tell you
what we've been working on a Media
Molecule it's the most ambitious thank
you it's it's sort of crazy and I'm
hoping today that I can kind of make you
all scratch your heads it's the it's the
most exciting thing I've ever worked on
and when we were making LittleBigPlanet
and tear away we learned a lot about
digital creativity so today I want to
tell you about the next step on that
journey we call it dreams you know that
feeling of lucid dreaming of moving
through impossible time and space you
know perhaps you started in the streets
of that city and then suddenly you're
diving into the deepest reaches of the
ocean it feels surreal and wonderful and
that's the sensation we're going for on
PlayStation 4 so we're building a place
where you go to play and explore the
dreams of others and then you can create
and share your own every individual
dream is seamlessly linked to the others
that sort of woven into an Open dream
averse you can get lost for hours
exploring journeying through the
imaginations of thousands of ps4 gamers
and the thing that unites them all is
that feeling of being in a dream but
when we tried to capture those fleeting
dreamlike moments we found that they
weren't any suitable tools out there and
we needed a new creative palette and of
course we'll be giving that palette to
you the gamers so we throw away the
usual polygons keyframes lists all of
that and we focused instead on sketching
collaboration immediacy and making it
feel like a game so let me show you how
it works it's as simple as moving your
controller to create your mark on the
world this everything you see here today
is on PlayStation 4 with no pre-made
assets the game looks like a moving
painting it's beautiful and leaves room
for your imagination you can sketch
collaboratively on your sofa live online
or build on the work of others you call
up their dreams and then remix collage
and link them together you stand on
their shoulders because in 2015 after
all everything is a remix and creating
is easier and more fun when you're in a
dream you don't need to stress over the
details we focus on making it quick
intuitive
and rewarding and we found that the more
enjoyable we make the creation side the
more very exciting and surprising are
the play experiences as you can see
anyone can piece together a whole
environment in just a few moments and to
bring your world to life you just reach
in and grab it performance capture is
puppeteering is the most natural way to
animate so I've only had a few minutes
today so rather than trying to explain
it all I just want to give you a taste I
hope it fills your head with questions
and that's natural every person we've
shown this to over the last four years
says it takes time to sink in so we'll
have much more to share at Paris games
week please stay tuned and in the
meantime I hope you enjoy some of the
first dreams realized a hundred percent
on PlayStation 4 thanks